MARK MIRCHANDANI: Looking to
host your own website, blog,
or e-commerce site?
Today we'll be introducing
you to the lab running
WordPress on App Engine
flexible environment.
In this lab, you'll get
to set up and recognize
all the benefits of WordPress
on Google Cloud Platform.
WordPress is one of the most
popular open-source content
management systems
and GCP can help
you run your website in an
effective and scalable manner.
By using App Engine,
we can make sure
that your website scales to
any number of viewers quickly
and automatically.
Google Cloud SQL and
Google Cloud Storage
will let you host your
database and files
using managed
infrastructure, so you
don't need to worry about
resizing virtual machines
or emergency downtime requests.
Basic knowledge of PHP
and Linux text editors
will be required to finish
this lab on QwikLabs.
First in this lab,
you'll make sure all
the appropriate
services are enabled,
then you'll set up App
Engine and Cloud SQL
to host the website and
database separately.
You'll also use
Google Cloud Storage
to host your media library.
At the end of the
lab, you'll know
how to fully deploy a
WordPress website on GCP.
You'll be using a student or GCP
account to work on these labs,
but if you want to get
started with your own account,
here's $300 to get you started.
Today, I'll answer a question
from Vinayak Hedge on YouTube.
He asks, don't you have any
tutorials for GCP IRT core?
I am trying to send data
from my Arduino to GCP
but I am unable to do
it as I am not aware
how to send data using MQTT.
Great question.
We've got some starter
open-source code
on GitHub that can help
you connect your Arduino
devices to GCP.
Check the link below
in the description
for more information.
We also have tons of tutorials
on Google Cloud IRT Core,
including an Internet of
Things QuickStart lab.
Click on the link in
the description below
to check them out
and get started.
We'll catch you next time
on Google Cloud Labs.
[MUSIC PLAYING]